[Music]
please don't get involved
what is happening kiddos it is monday
monday morning
it is may 23rd on this
glorious
calabasas california morning
it is good to see you guys man
um god a fan told me to say something
uh when i say thickies thickums thick of
tears he gave me a good one i forgot did
he write it down uh no he was like oh
yeah he's i should tell chin or uh darn
it
or mark so you remember god i forget
what it is
splash ct thank you um
yeah man philly what is up philly i was
uh in philadelphia
over the weekend man and it was
fantastic it was so freaking fun man
there's nothing like a philadelphia
crowd and that picture that is on your
screen right now that is the thick boy
squad you see david lucas there you got
justin there both killed it and then the
gentleman the middle this this uh
this picture is black and white you
can't tell but he is a redhead he's a
redhead his name is connor
mook
his name's connor mook and he he's been
doing sam for i think right right under
three years
and um
he's kind of he's a helium kid there in
philly he does all the spots there he
runs his own show at a bar there just
hustling just hustling and i did a uh
like a mean great just kind of a hangout
that uh suplex in philly my sneaker shop
this is a hoodie here
um
because they're my boys you'll see them
they provide all the shoes on the food
truck and all that stuff we talk all the
time my boy mike out there you know love
those guys absolutely love them so
um oh you can stay up chin you know you
can just go there's no picture so um
[Music]
you know i mean all these people the
kids are coming in blah blah blah and
then uh
mike goes oh do you know connor you know
i don't know economy i don't know the
local
philly comedy scene and uh he's like
yeah he's a beast man he's open for this
this guy i know that's cool man and uh
what are you doing tonight he's like i
don't know i'm probably trying to find
some spots i said well you can do my
shows are you good you have a type 5 and
he goes his exact words where i have a
clean five oh clean and what are you
trying to get on [ __ ] tonight's show
clean i said my crowd is not cleaning
this no i mean like a
fire clean i was like oh but you cuss or
reference the dicks or whatever he's
like yes like you're in my man
and uh yeah he went out there and did
the damn that damn thing man he crushed
it man
such a good kid and i think he's you
know you have a bunch of east coast
states coming up in the next few months
i think we just announced baltimore we
have boston we have uh
rhode island
um
yeah so those are the ones did my bro
adam already i didn't see you keep
screaming i'm really refreshed yeah
refresh keep going so yeah bald we just
went on sale in baltimore that's august
4th through the 6th i've never been
there and then boston uh laughed boston
i cannot wait i used to do the wilbur
theater but the problem with wilbur
theater is you do two shows right so you
might do a thursday friday sometimes you
do two on a friday but boston my son's
name is boston the i absolutely love
boston man home of whitey bulger which
is frowned upon but also very
interesting but um
the winter hill gang but the thing is
about boston is
the best part about being on tour is you
get to stay in the city for three nights
three days you really get to feel the
city i never get to hang out in boston
because i always just do the wilbur
theater i'm there one night then i'm
back on a plane boston's too far to fly
for one night so i was like you got to
find me a good club they found it it's
at the laugh boston out there i cannot
wait still love you wilbur i absolutely
love you wilbur first thing i've ever
done wilbur is in my heart but i just
need i need the reps too with the new
hour that's the thing the new trash
panda 2022 tour we're getting all these
emails from people all around going is
it the same hour is it the same half
hour that you released with the gringo
poppy it is not there's not a single
joke from the gringo poppy in the new
hour haul at your boy oh and the gringo
poppy hit a million son oh yeah yeah
thank you guys so much man
i can't thank you guys enough the fans
uh
man
talk about uh you know i've had anxiety
about this the whole time when
you know obviously the
clear path is to go with a major network
and do that stuff and you know have
agents big agents in the ca and they say
you know this is the route to go and
when you defy them and go now i'm put on
i'm have my team shoot it i'm gonna do
it i'm gonna mark it my way i'm gonna
pay for my own billboards my own
commercials and you know do it my way my
own music from little brow shot and chin
and you know i'm just gonna do it my way
which you know it's kind of it's not
what they do right they're like what
but
i think it paid off man i think it paid
off
that video that you guys made is
freaking sick man
um yeah i just
speechless freaking speechless man so i
can't thank you guys enough dude can't
thank you enough it's so freaking cool
man
i'm i'm so grateful i'm so humble
but the in the the way i show my
gratitude to you guys by working my ass
off it just gets better and better and
better and that's the way we're gonna do
it we think i'll be in three years what
do you think i'll be in five years what
do you think i'll be in 10 years
and we're on this journey together man
so it's cool yeah but i can't thank you
guys enough man that's a big deal and i
made a deal with the thick boy team
the whole staff here i said
i'll be dead honest i didn't think we're
gonna get close to a million i thought
we'd do around three to four hundred
thousand just being dead honest
i thought it'd be three four thousand
you know my agents like i told you dummy
that makes sense so i've had anxiety
about it but uh you guys believed it i
said okay i'll make you bet
since my team shot and we've been
promoting this thing like crazy i said
if the gringo poppy special hits a
million
if it's a million on youtube not eclipse
like the the
the puto clip on tick tocks over a
million that doesn't count no clips
nothing the actual special has hit a
million i will take the entire staff
like with everyone included the grav
you're looking about 12 people i said i
will take the entire staff of thick boy
to scopa for dinner
well it hit it hit a mill oh yeah and as
soon as you guys text me i found out you
guys posted that dope ass uh
sizzle
um
i uh hit up my boy
who owned scopa said yo
need thursday night
eight o'clock he went say less and he
knew it he goes this is for this the
millie i go this is the milly party so
this thursday night 8 p.m
scopa the whole squad's there man
my favorite restaurant dude my favorite
freaking restaurant they have the best
steak that t-boned even though
what's so dope about them don't have
signage the best bar best drinks
they just they just got a
tiger thick whiskey available there yeah
man
yeah the whole vibe there and dude
as far as la right like my life's in
different freaking
kind of
spot and when i came to l.a like scopa
was like our chairs me brian sasso deleo
like that was our chairs man we would
just go there and no matter what we were
going through we'd always meet at scopa
it was our like
you know you know how and friends they
hang out that uh
central perk
this is our central perk with and now
that i don't live there you know yeah i
come i go there maybe twice a year which
is such a shame still talk to uh marco
and pablo all the time but
yeah it's my favorite restaurant
favorite vibes best food you've been
there right then i think we went once
right for like a christmas party we went
to a restaurant one time marty
yeah yeah
yeah that was good
it was like six of us but that was yeah
that food is freaking amazing yeah the
drinks are awesome yeah drinks are
nattos and they have a speak a hidden
speakeasy we have to be a member to get
in the back is like this backdoor
entrance they take your cell phone
and in that speakeasy it's all like
1960s and 50s even the dr no drink
is uh newer than like 1963 or something
like that so it's just like
incredible i mean dude nuts it's so cool
yeah so so cool pasta obviously
ridiculous
but i'm telling you the the the sleeper
is the steak they have the best t-bone
in la dude
my favorite restaurant
my favorite freaking restaurant no diet
that day huh
i did have some uh uh philly
cheesesteaks
i i had
i
one and a half philly cheesesteaks in
philadelphia
not from gino's or any of that you know
not the fast food stuff like we had some
like really like angelos like some real
proper so freaking good and then right
by my airbnb was a place called it was
just said cheesesteak co
and it was like literally like next door
to us
cheesecake and we went in there it was
fantastic yeah it was great man it was
so so much fun
what else uh was dope about being a road
is right
every city i open up with a a local
reference jokes whatever it is it's
because i i write it and the the the
thing is is i write it in the green room
before i go on stage so you'll see the
clip where
um
for charlotte i just started doing in
charlotte i was like all right you just
force your creative and write and stuff
like that
so for charlotte you'll see the clip was
the mugsy bogues joke you know how
disrespect was they don't have a statue
the guy was 5'3 you know he dicks were
in his face all that stuff i wrote that
literally five minutes before i went on
stage
and then i do it thursday night and then
uh uh then i'll do it both friday shows
and then saturday i hire a videographer
if it's good enough to film it and i put
it because throw it i can never use that
you can't use it again so those are
throwaway so for every city it's those
local references
so for uh
philly we needed a videographer and i
put it on my instagram story you know
you get whatever 30 [ __ ] guys like i
can do it i can do i can do it
we we decided we're gonna go with this
guy
who worked with krista stefano one time
i kid up chrissy dee's like yeah he's
great man you love him blah blah blah
cool
and then um
the squad goes hey we got this dm for
this dude man he's involved with mma
he uh he shot all his content he does
all the stuff local references he's
basically a tour guide in philly you
should really try him out and i just
they sent me what he said he just seemed
like a genuine person said hey that
other guy will use him another time for
in another city
i got a good feeling about this guy his
name's alistair
if you click on the picture i think it's
on there
uh the black and white pick i'm sure
they tagged him
uh yep it's at m
cali underscore two one five
that's him right there yeah yeah he was
like do a lot content creator for your
favorite philly restaurants
um videographer
he's a dad he's a five-year-old or
six-year-old oh there's a picture of all
this right there yeah yeah oh son's cute
[ __ ]
he was dope he showed us around
everywhere too dude
he is
such a good person man i told him i was
like yo we're friends now man if i meet
somebody who's good at their job and
they're freaking
you know just a good person
you're in bubba so i'm gonna use him for
every east coast date we have a bunch of
east coast dates coming up there he is
with look at this freaking kid man
hey officer don't cuss when you post
your son oh [ __ ] tacos a little bit or
too aggressive yeah i'm aggressive the
kid's six
ouster [ __ ] loves these tacos all
right well he's six dude he's cute as
[ __ ]
yeah cute oh his wife's super pretty
jesus christ
he's just a good dude man good dude and
he uh
he used to fight mma to do muay thai he
rolls does all that [ __ ] and he's really
close with everybody in the local scene
as far as mma go so sean brady is really
close with um and then andre petrovsky
he's really close with so andre uh if
you if you go back and this last week's
show i gave him the mvp for the anaconda
choke and the first fight in the prelims
you look amazing
so andre hey you know dm's hey thanks
for the love man like for sure he's they
come to philly i'm like yep come to show
he's like cool can i get eight tickets
sure so it's andre petroski you gotta
give me tickets
so he comes to i think for one of the
friday shows
and uh i meet andre i told alice send me
the pic but dude the kid is in shape man
in shape cool dude
oh you met him yeah i went in the
groomer
yeah well i didn't know he came to the
green room yep i'm pretty sure as a
green room i'm sure you did but then i
was drinking a lot so i don't know
i i i i texas to the group there i
didn't see chin sober the entire time in
philly
i was on vacation basically so i want to
just enjoy but i was never i'm not like
a messy drunk i was just happy you're
like me yeah i never get i never get
hammered
i wish i had whiskey right now
are you sipping something i have to
because you give me some case the trip
was so mice we drank so or i drank so
much i'm like when i got here this
morning i was kind of like
a little shaky so i'm like yeah the way
to fix it a little bit of this yep yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're an addict so
that's cool
yeah i've told you before i am
don't go crazy though no i don't know
you just gotta
yeah just you know you never want it too
far right too far left if i veer a
little bit like politics you don't want
to get too far left too far right stay
in the middle baby yeah
things are good on both fans yeah stay
in the middle daddy stay in your lane
uh but yeah shout out to aleister man
just so talented you'll see him though
we'll post that uh clip just for philly
coming up soon
i think we're calling the the whole uh
thing that we're doing is area code
shorts
era code shorts some [ __ ] like that code
shorts yeah okay but the one affiliate
was way longer than the mugsy bogues bit
again to ben franklin
that's funny yeah it was a good time uh
you have a philly dude philly late show
dude it is the purge dude
insanely packed insanely fun it was so
cool dude yeah i talked to brows uh last
night and this morning he's like dude
it's so much fun being on the road blah
blah blah he's like we gotta do more
anytime you want me there i was like
dude
to me like
it's it's not about the money i'd rather
make less money and have be surrounded
by my close friends yeah being on
youtube it's about the experience thanks
brother
is this tiger thick i'm not gonna find
it
thank you sir
um
yeah but i told brows i'm like dude it's
there's nothing better there's nothing
better man when remember we're walking
around it's raining yeah it was like it
was a warm rain walking around seeing
ben franklin's house and doing all this
crap
it was such a good time so much fun yeah
and suplex was so fun dude
how good is this yeah the best chin got
some fire kicks yeah dude i'm gonna take
a picture of those and put them on my
instagram story i'm gonna go thick boy
as i always do uh because i'm not
wearing suplex sinks today i got these
uh jordan tokyos on
but i'm gonna take picture yours no with
your foot on it okay just for now fire
chin and i just i told him like just he
picked my first shoes out there because
you don't know kit no no but he knows
exactly what i like i love little
fluorescent highlights and stuff so he's
so dope what size are those 12s
why just curious
yeah they let the the whole squad got
kicks yeah jay got these fire new
balances
[ __ ] mark who you know basically wears
dead lifting shoes every day and sweats
he got these insane jordans just saw
them yeah these are not he's wearing
them today yeah i'm gonna take because
yours and marks for my uh monday thick
boy studio kicks today it's gonna be
yours and marks not mine that's what
we're gonna do hell yeah but you guys
both got fire kicks jay got those dope
new balances
justin got some vapes and some uh these
nuts new balances david got shoes for
him and his girl just shoes for his girl
and then then mike you know i love you
he you know when i say i'm a sneaker
head i keep it humble on how much of a
sneaker addiction i have when it comes
to clothes and stinkers the addiction is
real i'm obsessed with that stuff
so uh mike you'd be like oh this what
i'm thinking for you and he's been
telling me this whole time how you know
they're going to take care of me when
i'm there but so he gets out all his 13
so there's like five pairs and he's open
the box i go i got those i have those i
have those because you don't have these
of them i have those yes there's no way
you have these i'm like i have those
he's like jesus christ let me see what
else we got and he's naming the shoes
i'm like i'm telling you dude i have a
problem i have all those shoes already
he's like i don't know what the [ __ ]
we're gonna do then i'm like it's all
you don't have to do anything dude
you're so you guys they're such good
people and they're so nice to me and
there's a reason i have them on food
truck and they provide the shoes for the
fighters all that or you have to do
anything dude
and then he's like man the only thing we
have is a 14.
he's like but we have in the case is
like the holy grail he's like the case
the travis got jordan wands man i was
like
the mids he said yeah i'm like i don't
have those
sound be the most expensive shoe in the
store of course
so you saw me rocking those on saturday
night yeah it's pretty cool man
but yeah shout out to suplex love those
guys man
absolutely love this i just love philly
i love these coats man i like the
weather
it was hot i i i was next to a cop i'd
go to that coffee shop and just chill
there all day i fell asleep on the couch
on saturday i fell asleep on the couch
in this coffee shop the guy wakes me and
goes dude you gotta go man but he didn't
realize i came in the morning and came
back at three and afternoon before the
shows
sometimes you know because it's great
when you're on the road it's so much fun
it's like this frat house this bro
culture
but between mark and my brother and
justin nobody shuts up
it's they're doing
nine hour podcast non-stop but whatever
meant sports basketball it just it's so
much noise so on saturdays i go and i
knew
saturday philly shows you better come
correct because they get out of hand if
you let your line team you let philly
lions get a hand you get eaten alive
dude i know that i know that
the thing about this that if you're a
comedy event it's the famous bill burr
bit where he starts lighting the city up
that was because that crowd was going
bad on those phenomenal comics we think
they do to me
so i was nervous about them like i
shouldn't go get my mind right i haven't
been sleeping when i have insomnia so i
walk to a coffee shop in the morning i
was there at from like eight to ten
i leave but i leave out the back i come
back at three i wear the same drink it
was a eight shot uh ice espresso so
that's 16 shots before 3 p.m i have
problems
and uh i'm sitting on the couch and
finally just fall asleep
and the guy was hit woken up like i'm
homeless dude he's like what are you
doing man you've been here all day
you've been here since 8 am dude this
isn't a [ __ ] hostel
what are you doing this is in a homeless
shelter yeah you're going and i was like
well no no i was like and i'm like kind
of out of it i was like no
no i left and he's like no you didn't
like yeah i came out the back he's like
okay dude it seems like you've been
chilling i'm arguing with guys
and then he goes aren't you like a
famous person everyone here keeps they
were gonna they're taking pictures you
sleep and i was like oh my god dude
i'm like [ __ ] johnny depp
they come out and you know he's passing
out and tour and [ __ ]
i was just resting my eyes man let my
brain settle down because my friends
don't shut up that's all i was doing
but shout out to philly man goddamn for
sure time amazing time great freaking
time glad you came chen i'm glad yeah
thanks for having us too it's so much we
wouldn't
experience all this stuff it wasn't for
you so thank you yeah man of course
brother of course man i told brows
because brad's like man any time let us
know i'm like
you know besides those east coast ones
which is far for you guys to go to
philly like you know we have the next
one's portland's not far partly
portland's in two weeks portland have
you been in portland
i don't know portland's great portland's
a great city we're in portland in two
weeks after that it's yeah so we're in
portland june 9th through the 11th the
trash panda tour continues in portland
god portland might be the capital of
trash bandito i mean portland
portland
there's nowhere like portland dude so
you got portland june 9th through the
11th then we're in san francisco chin
you came there years ago yeah i remember
that would be easy all those are easy
for you
dude san francisco dude san francisco
june 17th through june 18th yeah the
cobbs
friday saturday cops friday cobbs robin
williams home
i love that club come on daddy
so you got san francisco june 17th the
18th san diego july 21st 23rd come on
dude it's all local yeah pretty close at
least yeah well i'll tell you the one
you should circle chin is boston
september 29th through october 1st i've
never been either and i'm and i'm going
to go to whitey bulger's old bar i think
it's called like special o's or
something like that apparently it's a
dump but i just want a picture sitting
at the on the stool where whitey bulger
chilled at
you know in the movie uh black mass
remember it opens up and his main like
henchman has his fat fingers in the
penis and he's just licking his fingers
and he goes i've watched you for the
last 10 minutes take your [ __ ] fat
fingers
put them in your mouth and put them back
in that bowl
that's special
i don't know this is it just says uh
the maiden
where do what
austin
triplos triple o close lounge
whitey bulger held court at triple o's
plotting murders and extortion the bars
upstairs room
yeah i want to go up in the upstairs
room
yeah see if you click on where's uh
triple o's lounge it's still there daddy
killing me on his two brothers own
operate triple o's lounge in boston
which served the headquarters white
bullish gang i want to use the bar as a
front for the game's point pretty sure
it's still open oh there goes it says
this triple o south boss is still open
click on that
closes down oyster and tacos restaurant
[ __ ]
those are still good though tacos and
oysters
tacos
tacos and oysters i'm not together but i
mean i love oysters and i love tacos
[ __ ] i was on the impression was still
open
god that ruined it
i get well i guess we'll go there yeah
this one know he was like his
his spirits there
dude our airbnb in philly man
though
listen my brother refuses to leave
negative reviews on airbnb i don't know
how it works he refuses to leave
he said well they can leave negro
reviews on us i'm like
but we have we don't do anything we're
gonna leave negative you see i don't
could affect this book in the future
but just be honest if it's great leave a
great review if it's shitty leave a bad
review but don't be mean about it just
but i came in this place didn't have
wi-fi
you know somebody was shot in the master
bedroom there was
blood
there's a blood stain on the mast
bedroom floor
dude my
the place was crazy crazy haunted so
haunted i just had a ghost all night
harassing me
yeah i think he's for my subreddit i
don't know anyways
um
but yeah man shout out to philly uh
portland you're next man i had two weeks
off
which your boy could use man
your boy could use two weeks off when i
say off it just means from the road i'm
still doing 19 podcasts a week
but yeah i get to see my son every night
taking him juicy tonight car shows on
sunday i can't wait dude cool man can't
freaking wait let's take a little break
few housekeeping notes to keep the
lights on and i'm gonna quit chatting
about philadelphia and we'll get
straight to the fight talk after this
because life can be overwhelming many
people are burned out without even
knowing it symptoms can include lack of
motivation you feel helpless trapped
you're not sleeping well maybe you've
insomnia maybe you're running a network
and you put too much on your plate and
then you're torn you got a right then
you just shot an hour and you put it out
and you write a new hour and you can't
sleep and then there's social media
and you're dealing with drama and you
need to start talking to somebody
take it from your boy here man i pride
myself on being mentally strong strong
as anybody out there but i needed help i
started seeing a therapist in person
the last few months and i can't tell you
how much it has helped me out and i'm
someone who didn't really believe in it
and it's just an unbiased opinion from a
professional man an actual person who
has dealt with
way worse problems and heard it from
people dealing with way bigger issues
than you think you're dealing with but
here's what's the best part the best
part is they give you the tools mentally
to navigate to whatever you're dealing
with you're feeling overwhelmed or men
or you're just too much on your plate or
you're having issues with your friends
they're gonna help you figure it out
what exactly is the problem how to
address it and move on but you have that
tool for the rest of your life it's
super important man and uh that's why i
can't stress enough man you need to talk
to professional and better help i
absolutely love this company man because
better help is custom
online therapy all right they do it
video or phone i do video and they even
do a live chat session with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to i
like to phone's like enough i like to
see them eye to eye all right it's much
more affordable than person therapy
which is very expensive and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours shop show listeners and viewers
you get 10 percent off your first month
at betterhelp.com slash shop s-h-a-u-b
that's betterhelphelp.com
oh this one's fun listen man maybe
you're at the gym you don't have a
trainer you're doing it yourself you're
not seeing the results that you want uh
maybe change up your diet again you're
not seeing the results that you want or
maybe you just don't want to go to the
gym you'll have motivation well if i
told you there was an app where they
have a special algorithm that learns
your goals your experience level maybe
you're new maybe you're a beast right
and then they craft it just for you it's
uniquely
crafted for your body type man that's
what this app does baby and what i'm
talking about is fit bod fit bod you
download the app on your phone android
iphones they got it all man and you have
access to your personalized workout
routine in an easy to use mobile app all
right it's like having a trainer 24 7
man it's great it's easy to use it's fun
to use it's motivational all right
because you don't want to wait to you
know new year new me do it right now the
summer is coming up man matter of fact
it might already be here but either way
it's never too late to get in shape and
be healthy all right because again this
algorithm that they use it's built on
your last workout and then the next
workout they make sure you're doing
exactly what you need to do to maximize
your results man with your exercise
three days a week twice a day every
workout is proven to be better than the
last because they're tracking all of it
muscle recovery you know balance your
workout plan with a variety of exercises
so you're not overworking hey bro you
just can't do bench every day you feel
me they're not going to let you do this
man build your fitness habit and become
a better version of yourself with fitbot
get 25 off your subscription or try out
the app for free when you sign up now at
fit bod dot me slash shob
that's 25 off your subscription when you
sign up today at fit bod dot m e slash
s-e-h-a-u-b
fit pod
um but there were some fights this week
let's get in the fight so i've been
talking about [ __ ] touring um
there's some fights this weekend man was
there ever on you know on the main card
which i watched last night because i'm a
degenerate also brandon your job though
you know you kind of gotta watch him
dude if you're gonna do a mma show so
here we are man um
you know
what sucks for me is when i have to
watch on a sunday night on espn plus
shout out to espn plus
and they're not fun we're just like
and if you kind of know that obviously i
know some of the results
yeah you know like you got you got three
split decisions on the main card
one regular unanimous decision and then
you know
the the the middleweight bout with uh uh
how do you say that no
no
ni
oh [ __ ] ginger johnny johanna in jakuani
yeah dope ass elbow yeah first round
chaos so that was fun but other than
that dude the the main event co-main
event
you know and i'm sure it's in your
current events there chin but it's just
like um
you know they're not gonna blow your
hair back when you gotta re-watch we
know the results there's nothing worse
dude when there's these born fights the
the the narrative on this card though is
we have a judging problem yeah and i
know dc gets into it and listen
listen to dc
listen in dc don't listen to these mma
heads who have never fought before don't
listen to you know these espn suits and
stuff like that
and my issue is
the narrative for so long when we talk
about judge and we go can't leave in the
hands of the judges i remember danny's
he used to do a after weigh-ins he'd get
all the fighters together and go you
know these judges suck man don't leave
in the hands of the judges
yeah yeah no doubt we're trying man it
just so happens we're at the upper
echelon of fighting dude
i know of course i want to walk out
there and head kick him get out in three
seconds and get the bonus that's the
plan
it's very if that's your goal it's very
rare that happens that stuff happens
when you're not expecting it if you go
in there expecting it you get your nose
shattered and some croatian is going to
give you 19 stitches on your eye and you
have to reconstructive no surgery you're
going to be in for a fight so having me
in croquet i was like i'm a starches
dude no you're not
it happens when you're not looking for
it man so you know
listen to dc
he's literally one of the greatest to
ever do it the guy has been around
combat sports whether it's wrestling or
mixed martial arts for
since he was a freaking kid he is an
expert he has his
doctorate degree in mixed martial arts
there's nobody more educated well spoken
in the game i don't care these analysts
this guy works for espn this guy works
for mma i don't care who it is
dc has walked the walk at the highest
level in every aspect at multiple weight
classes against the biggest names on the
biggest cards and has passed the test
when dc speaks
it should be the end of the story i
don't care if it's coming from i love
big john i i don't know this is no shade
on big john
i don't care if it's big john i don't
care if it's dana white i don't care if
it's a current fighter right now
there's nobody better in the game
there's nobody more educated
he dc's not doing this for clicks you
know you know those pods and those
personalities whatever it is comedy
fighting youtubers
they thrive off drama they don't have
the talent to do it any other way they
have to get the clicks through the drama
they're basically tmc they do it from
the for the drama
there's no longevity in that you
and nobody's an actual fan they just
want to they want to be part of the
drama nobody's a fan of that they they
like they like the drama but they sell
merch off the drama let me know it goes
for you you're not going to create an
entire career off drama
dc is a no-nonsense
type of dude he doesn't do anything for
clickbait
love chelsea one of the
top five favorite people in sports you
guys know how my love for jail zone is
on [ __ ] real but
does the clicky stuff i can't do it i
literally can't do it we've tried here
it's not for me it's uh it gives me
anxiety it's not what i like
no that's not what i do man oh you get
more views then i don't want more views
i i it's not what i do i i just can't
bring myself to do it man i can't so
dc's the exact same way
so when d again when dc talks everybody
should listen and you should take it as
word dude he's been in there so this is
daniel cormay's thoughts on the judging
in the main event and another fight on
that main card that open it that went to
split decisions regarding the judging
and again
this long ran about all this [ __ ] and
you know how much i love dc and how he's
the best all that this all starts with
there seems to be this narrative in
mixed martial arts where we're okay
when we just chalk up to the judging
sucked but nobody ever does anything
ever notice dana every time to judge you
can't leave the hands of judges dude i'm
[ __ ] trying dude
i'm trying
it's just
the guy i'm fighting is really [ __ ]
good dude
i can't get him out of here i sometimes
i have to depend on the judges can you
imagine if you know whatever whatever
sport you like soccer football if they
went
yeah can't depend on the refs man
you just you can't you know they're
gonna they're gonna do what they do
that's not good enough for me we
wouldn't put up with it in any other
facet at a high level ufc is at a high
level
there there this has come
it's been coming a long time and finally
it's at a threshold where everybody in
this space whether you're a former
fighter who rants on a camera like me or
you're a current fighter or you work in
marketing for the ufc or you're dana
white or you're big john mccartney or
josh thompson and you have a large
platform if you're around your luke
thomas we have all
got to just quit saying ah can't leave
in the hands of the judges that's no
that's not okay with me because it's
ruining fighters careers they're getting
half their paycheck because these judges
don't know what they're doing we have
got to address it we have to
how long you want to wait
it's a huge issue in the sport and we
all know it
i don't know anybody in this space who
goes i have judges they're trying their
best never now the judges man they're
actually they're pretty good never we
just all go yeah they suck what can you
do
no that doesn't work for me the reason
boxing is dying although it's kind of on
a
rise now because of jake paul i'll say
that again look at the analytics
the reason boxing has become more
popular than ever is because of jake
paul that is black and white you can
hate on the guy you want the reason
boxing views are up is because of logan
and particularly jake paul
boxing needed
that to get people to [ __ ] tune in
and a big problem with boxing is
corruption
so you look at uh canelo triple g you
know those fights
what some fights you look like how the
[ __ ] yeah they have their hands in their
pocket dude it ruined the sport
learn from that
because this can ruin this sport
but we all including the fan base we're
all held accountable i'll take ownership
i do it even when i was fighting like ah
man
dude i beat andre orlovsky i beat that
guy they gave it to andre alaska he's
more famous than me
way more famous than me especially at
the time way more famous they gave to my
fame dude
that's not okay
but again in my head i went ah yeah
i should have done this instead i should
have done this i said no dude you
shouldn't have you should be okay with
it going to a professional
paid
[ __ ] jury of three
who are supposed to be experts
the problem with the sport is though is
there
you know big john who wrote the rules so
listen to big john he wrote the rules
the issue is is each judge has their
bias
so one judge might think and this what
happened the main event which is why i'm
doing this long rant on [ __ ] judging
in the main event if you watch that
and you're a person who thinks
uh whoever did the most damage won the
fight
so if when they are when they are on
their feet this person is inflicting
more damage that's my number one
criteria
you're gonna give it
to to to the other person
now if you're a person that goes okay um
holly holm
controlled the octagon more in the
clinch for over 10 minutes she had her
back against the cage
that's octagon control even though she's
not doing damage that is octagon control
because when you think about it
you know um
that girl that holly was fighting what's
her name caitlyn vera caitlyn vera
and this is no shade on caitlyn very
this has nothing to do with her this is
just an example
caitlyn vera
does not want her back against the wall
her entire train camp i guarantee they
didn't say hey let holly control you in
the clinch and keep your back against
the cage
so to me
that is a movement
that proves that holly is winning the
fight because she's doing something that
that opponent does not want to do
that would be octagon control that would
be control of the fight that the
narrative should be that holly is
controlling the fight making viera do
something she does not want to do to me
that goes farther than
let's say the formats they're on their
feet even she wobbled her in those four
minutes
she's trying to win the fight get her
out of there more power to you
but it is a sport and going off the
judging if this person
if it's a 15 minute 25-minute fight for
this example 25-minute fight if for 25
minutes
one of them for 20 minutes may the other
do something they don't want to do
how in the world would you give it to
the other
person it doesn't make sense to me
but again if i was a judge this is the
problem if i was judged that's my
personal opinion
i think it's right i think it's that
sports
that's sports it's like steph curry
hitting threes and then going yeah the
only reason they want to hit [ __ ]
threes
yeah but um
the other team didn't want to shoot
threes he kept [ __ ] shooting threes
so he beat their game plan and [ __ ]
won there's a score there's no there's a
score in ours but it's you know there's
not it's all bias that'd be like steph
curry hitting threes and the judges only
give them one point
but this other judge gives them four
points and this other judge gives them
zero points and then they gotta come to
agreement how insane is that how hard is
that to follow
it's a [ __ ] show
here's the problem
you're talking
millions and millions and millions of
revenue dollars that are taken
from the fighters purses their pockets
the way the fighting works is if they
win they get this amount
they lose they get this amount
and a lot of is predicated off that
judging which is willy-nilly we have no
idea what the judge is going to do one
might advocate for more damage than when
it advocates for more octagon control so
their split
comes down this [ __ ]
and none of them came up in a lot of
them not all of them a lot of them did
not come up in the mixed martial arts
they're all going to have their bias and
that's a huge
there can't be biased opinions dictating
somebody's income
in sports at a high level here's another
example imagine if a ref in the nfl
didn't value passing the football he
valued running the football
and he was in control of who won the
game
so when the [ __ ] chiefs throw 60
times the game because pastor mahomes is
a [ __ ]
alien with a rocket arm
if he went um i i don't like to pass a
man that's only two points and then if
the other team ran the ball slightly
more and he goes that's 10 points
and we didn't know the score to the end
and at the end he goes i value running
more so i'm actually going to give it to
the steelers or the titans who run a lot
i'm going to give to the titans the
score is actually 50 to two
like whoa hold on hold up
just because the steelers ran the ball
more you get more points is yeah i value
run it's harder
and then the other ref goes well i value
passing i have the score 60-1 because i
value passing
but we don't know to the end of the game
and you're praying oh hopefully my team
won i think they won i think that enough
that's no different if you're team holly
and she's running the ball but you don't
value running
she's like she can't win
so if you're a coach
you're gonna look uh obviously the game
plan is to [ __ ] knock them out every
time but it's tough to do
so if you're a coach what you have to do
now because the judging is so
[ __ ] up
you have to look at the judges
and look into the pat shouldn't have to
do this this is what you have to do
that's what i do if i was a coach i
would look who i would ask early who are
the judges you know oh this one this one
really values damage
but they don't care about octagon
control so holly if you're going to get
in the clinch and control her against
the cage
we're going to lose the fight you have
got to stay on the outside and throw
light kicks maybe we don't knock her out
but we will win the fight if because the
judges because these two judges which is
all one need two out of three these two
judges really value leg kicks
they're biased towards leg kicks
and if the other way hey these two
judges all they care about is out gun
control
and you can do your thing if you can
knock her out great but let's really
focus on keeping her back against the
wall that's how we will win this fight
how insane is that man isn't it nuts
it's
2022 bro
it's just up for debate
it's literally there's biases in the
sport with the judges
you can't keep doing this man
you can't do it and here's the other
thing
if you've ever been to fight i've been a
ton of them i've been in there if you're
cage side where those judges at you
can't see everything there's no way
it's human error you can't see
everything they should be in a
undisclosed location [ __ ] alaska
wherever la
you they could fly me to see fly them to
[ __ ] vegas put it put them outside
the strip in a closed facility which
just it's more than three
so it's better we lose five
do ten
so we know exactly who wins you know
they should not be cage side because
you're they're going to be swayed
because remember they're human so if
they can hear the coaches so if you're
listening to uh keep forgetting vieira's
camp
if you listen to his coach it's going to
sway your opinion if that coach going
you're losing every single round girl
now does that coach believe that deep
down no what he's doing is he knows how
to get the best out of his fighter so
he's going i know if i tell her that
she's losing she's gonna increase the
productivity she'll increase the
aggressiveness she's gonna start doing
that what we've been working on all camp
now i know she might be winning two of
these
rounds that we've already had out of the
five she's she's one two but i don't
tell her that because i tell that she's
gonna she's gonna let off the gas so i
have to motivate her here's the problem
with that those judges a lot of times
can hear that so they're gonna be swayed
by that
or they miss
vice versa maybe they can't hear them
and they're here in holly's corner
going oh my girl you're this is not good
or you're you know this this this
but even
they and i think it's a mistake and
we're learning this now and you know
it's no shame on it because this is
interesting to get inside baseball with
the coaches between the rounds i i i do
enjoy it i've never heard anything
that's blown me away it's all pretty
basic stuff because you think about it
you're in a heightened sense of reality
you're fighting another human being
professional cage fighter in a steel
cage in your underwear you have no shoes
on no socks it's insane
that coach is trying to be very clean
precise and simple so you hear stuff
like breathe
make sure you use your jab they're not
getting too detailed because that
fighter is not going to download all
that in one minute and really by the
time the stool gets there you're looking
at 30 seconds
so what's the most i can get out of my
fighter in 30 seconds
but remember it's miked up coaches it's
miked up so what you say
is gonna
sway the fans and the judges
depending which who's micked up that
round it's not good dude i think miking
the coaches although it's fun and it's
inside baseball and it's cool to see
it's doing more damage than good some
dude almost got canceled last week
because he called him dirty brazilians
in reference to cheating he almost got
fired cancelled dude he has to deal with
that now he'll never get over that
i don't need a mike to know that greg
jackson is a good coach or trevor
whitman's good coach or name any coach
you want you write faber
[ __ ] uh all these monsters i don't
need them miked up it's very simple they
have 30 seconds to get their
narrative out to get their
to get the most out of their fighter
but what it's doing especially in this
case
is
people are so upset that holly lost
right
because how many of you listen
to the viewers coaches go you're losing
every round you're losing we got you
going you're losing
i would challenge
does he actually believe that
or is he just trying to get the most out
of his fighter he knows this fighter the
best
the issue is now is the internet is so
upset because they heard that and you're
the coach you thought she was losing
again
he's doing what he needs to do to get
that fighter to try to increase
productivity to try and increase the
game plan he doesn't believe they're
losing
when you go to the corner and sometimes
it's like oh dude this you're crushing
this little keep doing what you're doing
you know
the crowd's going oh yeah he's question
are they crashing are you just listening
to a corner who's extra bias who's
trying to get the most out of the
fighter
so i think
you got to get rid of the the mics in
the corner
i don't it's it's doing more harm than
good some dude almost got cancelled
become brazilian cheaters it's not good
and this side we're in and everyone
wants to you know pick out everything
they say and try to cancel people if you
get these coaches in trouble remember
most of these coaches
used to be
[ __ ] fighters
they're gonna say some wild [ __ ]
and sometimes a fighter needs some wild
[ __ ] it's like you remember mark henry
was judging uh or i'm sorry uh coaching
uh uh marlon mariah remember that and
he's against henry cejudo
he was lighting him up and then henry
cejudo just took over took over start to
break him
nobody knows that fighter better than
mark henry who's to me i would say the
best coach in the game top to bottom
detailed
all around the best frost is up there uh
greg jackson uh i can name all the
coaches you want but
personally to me again i'm biased
personally to me it's mark henry i've
been with all the coaches i've never
seen anybody like mark henry mark henry
is our vince lombardi mark henry is our
nick saban
he is
at the time i don't know where
now but at the time up
sassed with the x's and o's
i went there for my cro cop fight for a
week because i heard how great he was
he i get there i'm in jeans
he goes hey can you come down to the
basement like i guess i meet his family
just a great family he owns i think it's
called pinos or something like that this
great pizza place he's a religious dude
his wife is great they're giving me food
they're just the most endearing loving
people of all time super religious like
such a
loving environment positive
he works with just these savages and i
get there off the plane
from la i'm sorry from denver at them
from denver to [ __ ] um new jersey
they're in new jersey
i stay at his house
i'm
30 minutes removed from a
five hour flight to new jersey from
denver four hour flight maybe four hours
thirty minutes he goes can you go to the
basement
i'm like what you just take your shoes
off i'm in jeans i'm dressed like a [ __ ]
bite tight jeans on you know what i do
i haven't eaten yet
the the food's getting his wife's making
food upstairs he goes i just want you to
move around shadow box for me
for 45 minutes i'm dripping sweat shadow
boxing jeans and a [ __ ] t-shirt
a nice t-shirt and
tight jeans with no shoes on in his
basement on the cement
he wrote
20 pages of notes on what i'm doing
wrong wanted to improve on and then took
that in the next morning in the gym
implemented and made sure i tightened
things up
he was one of the reasons i beat murko
crow cop
he was one of the major reasons he
picked up he goes hey man
here's what you need to do those double
legs those early double eggs this time
that's all mark henry it's all timing
i spent
one week with him
that's how good he is
so if you remember marlon mariah is
going back to nobody knows their fighter
better than the coach if they know him
well
mariah started off lighting henry pseudo
up and hanging pseudo you're not going
to break henry it's impossible isis
couldn't waterboard that man and break
him it's not going to happen there's
guys like that in the ufc just the the
the mentality of these guys that's what
separates these guys everybody has
skills it's the mentality you're not
breaking dc you're not breaking jon
jones you're not breaking izzy you're
not breaking alexander volkanovsky
you're not
it is literally impossible
it can't happen
can't break them
never get a break no matter how many
times take them down no bad position
they always will find a way to figure
out and come back the only thing that
hurts them is sometimes the clock runs
out
you're never gonna break them it it
could they could go a hundred rounds and
khabib saying down over and over you
can't break them you gotta put them put
their lights out or choke them out
so
with marlon marias who had all the town
in the world from the world champ world
series comes to uc home to the [ __ ]
wolverines
you'll remember in that mark henry goes
think about your mom remember this he
pulled the [ __ ] emergency cord just
dude this is how bad again he goes think
about your mom in the favela right now
and you're here and you're thinking
about [ __ ] quitting
think about your mom you have one round
left
and then he goes out there and you know
he quit
how do you see what made him quit
the point of that is is if you're
listening to that and you're a judge and
you're going oh man that's intense
mark understand you think about your mom
favela this offsea isn't going well
so it's gonna sweat like it's gonna sway
you man
like he said it's very rare those
coaches say something that's gonna you
know
be a light bulb we're like oh that oh
that makes sense that's why holly's home
against cage oh i got it never dude
never never never it only hurts the
fighter because it's it's given a
narrative especially online where a lot
of this hate lives a lot against
hollywood has nothing to do with it it's
this this narrative so dc
let's get to dc dc says
that is where i think the judging gets
[ __ ] up a little bit it's even rarely
cusses where does he do this at his
youtube channel he sees
on youtube if it's in the first five
minutes get uh demonetized
that that one's on the house dc
i've learned the hard way bubba
uh this is where i think the judging
gets [ __ ] up a little bit because uh
vera does not want to be oh there we go
again here's the thing
i i don't see any of this the when when
i see it you guys see it i don't see any
of this i'm not on social media i see
none of this so i don't know any of the
narratives so this is just even more
evidence of i'm on the right track this
is daniel cormier
heavyweight champion strike force
light heavyweight champion of the ufc
heavyweight champion of ufc
best commentator that we have not named
joe rogan daniel cormier hall of famer
daniel cormier all right
he says that's where i think the judging
gets [ __ ] up a little bit because
vieira does not want to be against the
side of the octagon being held by holly
holm regardless of what you think in
terms of damage
she doesn't want to be there
to my point
if she had her choice
she'd have holly
up against the octagon or she'd be out
in the center striking but instead she's
controlled for more than 10 minutes and
i think that's andre uh reactions show
he's referring to the corner i assume
andre's the corner man
which we all heard
i think andre's reactions show what he
thought or how he thought the fight was
playing out but once again it's on the
judges once again he said it three times
once again
they keep on making these mistakes i
would think or we just don't know what
the hell we're watching
and i would caveat that with i think we
know what we're watching the major
issues the judges don't know what the
[ __ ] they're watching
that's the biggest issue
and it happened in that first fight with
uh jung young and eric anders i know
you're rooting for [ __ ] jung young
chin and that's fine but you know
it's
you can't have
biased judges
at this level in 2022.
i it doesn't work for me more i've been
saying for years
it doesn't work for me go can't leave in
the hands of the judges
it doesn't work when the president ufc
dana before every freaking fight i said
freaking not [ __ ] every frick and
fight
gives a speech after wayne's it goes my
best advice for you guys is don't leave
in the hands of the judges now he's
saying that for two reasons being the
owner of the ufc i think he's just the
president now there's different owners
he's lost stock though anyway
he goes
the reason he's saying that don't even
the judges because
now this narrative right sucks for holly
sex riviera it's not cool dude
but also don't leave the judges means
fight to win
fight to take chances fight to be
exciting because when you're exciting we
get more eyeballs when you're exciting
we get more money problem with that is
when you're exciting you open you open
yourself up to begin you get finished
faster
so there's this you know so remember
love dana i have no animosity towards a
guy at all he's done a phenomenal job
best ever do it kudos to him all the
money in the world
but remember he's the only he's the
president of the ufc he wants exciting
fights
even though he knows that the judging
[ __ ] sucks
that's why he goes he to it gives him
more credit when he goes don't leave the
hands of judges we don't know what
they're gonna do
instead
his
number one journey before he leaves this
world before he leaves the ufc which i
don't think he ever will but before he
leaves the ufc
if i'm dana white
we're set on money dude they've never
made more money we have all the town in
the world everybody wants to be here
before he to leave his mark
fix judging how about that
you've already done it dude you've taken
the ufc from this
small
niche sport to one of the top five in
the world kudos check you taking this
company that was a two million dollar
investment and they'll value that four
billion sold for four billion so that's
what it's worth
four billion dollars
kudos check
you've taken the guy in conor mcgregor
that became the most
famous athlete on the planet due to your
wittiness your smartness your iq
a lot of it has to do with conor don't
get me wrong but a lot of is dana white
then white had the the hindsight to go
i'm open to floyd connor
even though we know
conor wasn't going to win that fight and
it could be potentially a black eye on
the ufc he was still open to it it's one
of the most watched fights of all time
made conor even more famous which
brought more eyeballs to the ufc
kudos chuck
you even implemented women's fighting
into the ufc which you said you never
were going to do years ago but then you
did it with ronda rousey
you've changed the game
forever
now some of the women are the best
biggest most
highest earning famous people on the
planet
chuck kudos
we have all that your first ballot hall
of fame for sports entertainment
hands down you the closest thing you are
by far the closest thing to vince
mcmahon the wwe
and he's predicated his business model
off wwe which you know is insanely
successful you've done that
check
kudos all that
dude when you pass away dana they're
gonna build a [ __ ] statue on the las
vegas strip it's gonna be massive dude
like your [ __ ] ben franklin
philadelphia
like your rocky balboa but you're a real
dude they're gonna put that
somewhere in las vegas i guarantee you
when you pass away i bet you you're so
successful you're so good at your job i
bet you they do it in the next five
years in vegas
that's how big of a deal that's how
smart that's how successful you've made
this company
jack
kudos
but your number one goal if you want to
leave your mark but you've left a huge
mark huge mark
all kudos to you you've left such a big
mark it looks like my undies when i wear
whitey tighties i got streaks you've
left so many great streaks
so many streaks
but the one streak that will change the
game forever dude
like the starting line of a nascar track
the one streak that you need to do my
undies do look like the star line of the
indy 500 sometimes at 38 years old 39 i
always forget that at 39 years old
there's a reason why i wear camouflaged
underwear there's a reason why i don't
[ __ ] with white underwear i only do dark
colors daddy and that's a cheat code for
you boys out there all you grown men i
know it's tough you have the hairy asses
stuff like that manscape.com prone coach
shop get those hairy asses
use that lawnmower 4.0 get rid of that
jumanji jungle between your legs i feel
you dog it's tough you try to wipe clean
it's sometimes it's mission impossible
sometimes it is so difficult i'm better
at [ __ ] calculus than wiping my ass
and i have streaks dude at 39 i'm a
father of two with streaks you know how
that makes you feel as a man
but for dana
for dana you want to leave your biggest
streak and you have so many streaks so
many successful streaks the biggest mark
you can do is fix judging but you pay no
attention because here's and now the
caveat with this and if i'm dana this
would be if he hears this
and they're in the meeting on thursday
or friday when the [ __ ] they do their
meetings there's no big fights this week
right so when the team gets together
like
hey man we listen to the shop he's the
best in the game
i don't think he always say he'd like
you're fired get out
but this is how i picture my head
hey listen to the shop joe man uh yeah i
should describe thick boy oh he's
special just went over a million dana
yeah he's crashing it man even though
you've
tried to kill him um yeah so he was
saying that you've done all this stuff
he's giving me so many compliments man
then he went on this weird rant about
how his streaks in his underwear at 39.
uh sorry besides point but he's saying
to to to
to leave your mark on the sport you got
to fix judging that's the last thing you
have to do before you sail off to the
sunset and they build a statue of you
and he made something up like he knows
who's going to build the statue but
they're waiting till he fix judges i
think he's full [ __ ] there
his reddit said he's full of [ __ ]
anyways so uh
[Music]
you need to fix judges what he's saying
before you retire
dana's gonna go
judging is a commission thing it's not a
ufc thing so it's the california
commission
it's the nevada commission it's the
florida commissions the new york
commission
i can't deal with that i don't have
control over them if it was our thing we
would
but you can't if it'd be uh you know
when you talk about monopoly and
conflict of interest then you're talking
about wwe because wwe doesn't have refs
right well they have a ref but don't
have judges there's no judges
but imagine if
the dallas cowboys hired their own
referees
you're not going to get a lot of holding
calls so if the ufc had their own judges
which is illegal they would be able to
dictate who would win then it's the wb
which we can't have i get that here's
the thing uncle dana here's the thing
uncle dana
dana here's on the thing dana here's the
thing
when you shake the trees the leaves fall
daddy so if you every time you had a mic
in front of your face which you never
met make it mic you don't like like
myself
no hate there dude
if when you do these interviews you
start
coming up with ideas on how to change
judging what we should do they're gonna
listen
because the those commissions
make the majority of their money off the
ufc what else are the fight commissions
what else are they making money off of
go
boxing
absolutely not
there's
six big boxing fights a year there are
52
amazing fight cards that the ufc puts on
thanks to you
52.
the dollars talk man if you go
listen we're not fighting in
this city we're not fighting in nevada
which is their the capital of the ufc
it's fight town central if he goes man
until the nevada commission does this
this and this we're not fighting there
i guarantee you if you said that on a
friday by monday they're making changes
daddy guarantee it dude
but the problem is
is
you're already set
and we're under this notion because
we've all been brainwashed coming up in
the sport new age sport that this is
just the way it is
that's the problem
when we all start
fighting back and saying no this isn't
right dude there has to be a better way
to do this but nobody
nobody
gives it any attention because we all
assume we can't fix it
not the problem we can fix it
we just got to address it more we got to
bring it up we got to bring more
attention to it just like anything in
life the more attention you can give to
it the more you highlight it the more
you show that there's issues with it the
more support you're going to get it's
like if you have a toxic reddit that's
been harassing for six years never said
anything you just assume ah part of the
game it's not though it's not there's
hate then there's harassment and when
you start addressing it and highlighting
how negative and toxic and dangerous it
is
well then people go hold up dude
this ain't right we gotta do something
about this and then you get more support
than you've ever had
and that's the way you can do it so if
dana goes this isn't right let's fix
this
people and go man he's right you're the
most famous
person in combat sports of all time
the most thing about this
and it's kind of a
it could be a good or bad thing i'm not
saying it's a bad thing i think it's a
good thing because there's one constant
you see
the most famous people in the ufc are
not the fighters
the most famous people in the ufc
are dana white the president of the
company dana white he's a personality
you see him on the elk boys now he's a
bar stool with robbie he's all over man
he's as famous as they [ __ ] get
the only guy who's
uh mark cuban with mavericks and jerry
jones
about the only people that come close as
far as owners
jerry buss when he was alive
uh maybe phil jackson
michael jordan owned the what the
[ __ ] grizzlies for a little bit
the wizard i know you played for the
wizards and
but when you think about it who owns
these big corporations like roger
goodell's not famous do he gets
he basically has to act like [ __ ]
putin everywhere he goes he has to make
sure someone's trying his food before he
eats it so they don't poison people
[ __ ] hate roger goodell you look how
much money roger goodell makes anyways
the thing is with dana
and with our sport again i'm not saying
this issue but the most famous people in
the ufc are not the fighters
in every other sport the most famous
guys are always the guys that risk it or
gals that risk it on the field or inside
the cage or inside that uh on the
hardwood floor on the tennis courts
they're always the most famous
in mixed martial arts
the most famous people are ones that are
not fighting it's dana white and joe
rogan
those are the two most powerful and most
famous people
inside that stadium that arena
every single night no matter who's on it
dana especially rogan is more well known
than any fighter ever fight inside the
ufc not even close
because their business is not predicated
off wins and losses
they're featured on every single fight
card unless it's like a weird fight
night and they don't go but for the
majority of the views of the ufc
i can guarantee you there's one constant
it ain't conor it ain't nate diaz ain't
horry mozzarella it's not kobe covington
it's not izzy it's not francis it's not
alexander volkonovsky it's not patron
saint it's not shepchenko it's not
amanda nunez it's not brian ortega it's
none of that it's not glover texera it's
none of that
it's not khabib
it's it there's one constant
every single major pay-per-view it's
dana white joe rogan
and they have so much influence
they have all the power
conor has some power he needs to want to
fight but
in general fighters don't have that much
power you we just chalk it up to addis
complain especially if
for holly holm right she came and said
this judge is ridiculous after i won
that fight
she could have done more man to finish
it so he can knit pick it apart and
again whatever if you're a vr fan out
whatever
but dana and joe don't play that game
and they have all the power
their their business isn't a credit card
wins and losses let's predicate off
them talking and
and for joe breaking down the fights
talking about the fights being
personality for dana running in the
business but they're the most famous so
if dana and joe go hey man
we gotta make a change between the two
of them
are you [ __ ] me
if they said it today would say monday
by wednesday morning there's gonna be
changes
but again even rogan even dana everybody
who's majorly involved in the sport
[ __ ] endeavor in denver uh endeavor
endeavor who owns oh is it uh wme who
owns the ufc all of them included go ah
these judges man
that's not gonna work for me any longer
as a fight fan as a ufc alumni that
doesn't work for me
we've given that too much of a pass it's
time to address it
it's gotten out of hand
it's time to address it
and it starts with the two most famous
people in sport really it starts with
dana
starts with him
it'd be so easy for them to fix this
again dude like i told you back to the
streaks in your undies you have a lot of
major streaks
kudos to you you have all the money in
the world before you leave this sport
before you leave this earth to wherever
you're gonna go for if you're elon musk
fan which he is you think we're in a
simulation
and you're probably not gonna do
anything because then it's like what's
the point but if you believe in a higher
being before you go up to them big
pearly gates
god or a lot whoever you believe in is
gonna have a a list there he's gonna go
all right each in the ufc from two
million four billion women's sports hell
yeah dude that's cool wow what you do
for conor's really cool man oh man you
paid for bobby green's brother's funeral
that's [ __ ]
cool judging though
you never addressed it can't let you in
my man i can't let you in
and your money's no good here
it's the one thing he has to do before
he leaves the sport
has to
it
i'ma wrap this up with this it doesn't
work for me anymore going
that's judging
because that's a sheep mentality that is
weak [ __ ] man this is a huge issue we
have to address and you have all the
power to do it i beg you i beg the
fighters i beg the analysts i beg the
entertainers who are ranting the cameras
on youtube i [ __ ] challenge mma
junkie mma fighting ariel knows this
ariel's smart as [ __ ]
if all of us luke thomas brian campbell
all the big boys
all of us if we got on here and until it
changed you bring attention to it i
guarantee you even though the ufc does
not hire the commissions it's out of the
control it's not out of our control we
have all the power we have all the
voices we have all the say to change the
landscape of the game but
nobody's doing [ __ ] and i'm not famous
or powerful enough to change it
there has to be help
dana should feel so good if he got if he
made the change
now what would you do i don't know
that's the other problem
people go oh just open scoring no then
just listen to shitty scoring in real
time that doesn't help it doesn't fix
anything
i get to you guarantee you there's way
smarter people who have looked into this
and have an idea on how to change it i
guarantee you if dan went fire off your
best if you went to a staff on thursday
moment what i want all
50 of you to do however many has [ __ ]
hired garyvee that figures out
everything guys
brilliant
ask elon musk dude [ __ ] call your boy
trump
he puts out fires
come on dog
you're surrounded by smart bra people
you're smart as [ __ ] rogan's smart as
[ __ ] you're telling me between the mma
community you think about all the
analysts
thomas ariel campbell mma junkie mma
fighting
any bloody elbow all these outlets big
john
bro you get some old heads forest
griffin randy couture kenny florian
all these brilliant people
you're telling me if we sat in a room
for two hours we couldn't come up with a
plan that you can enforce
and if they don't abide by these rules
you don't fight in that [ __ ] city you
know how fast they would change
we have
all the power
all the power what's not going to work
for me any longer is [ __ ] over
fighters they're getting half their pay
or they're getting
ducked freaking leveled down in the
queue to fight for world title because
three judges don't know what the [ __ ]
they're watching
that's an issue in professional sports
in 2022 that's real you let it ruin
boxing boxing the mafia got their hands
and the ju all the state all that crazy
[ __ ]
the the managers got their hands on the
judges so you'll hear these scoring
cards and even with that because we're
so conditioned we go
boxing judge and it's crooked
what
imagine if the dallas cowboys
were just winning the super bowl every
year because of cheating referees that
they paid and had their hands in the
pockets
who would put up with that you think
philadelphia eagle fans would put up
with it
you think denver bronco fans will put up
with there would be a [ __ ] riot
what you saw january 6 at the capitol
ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] with the dallas cowboys
see what happens [ __ ] with the denver
broncos see what happens [ __ ] with the
chicago bear fan base the pittsburgh
steeler fan base you want to see people
get riled up
[ __ ] them over where they won a game but
the refs cost them the game
let me know how that goes for you
there's gonna be some changes real fast
no i guarantee you you going to
pittsburgh and they were losing games
they should have won because of judging
and refereeing
guarantee this change i guarantee you
that fan base
that massive fan base would not go
that's all right that's just what we
deal with man that's judging
when you say it like that when you say
it out loud how insane is it
that the mma fan base goes
that's judging
how long are you guys going to do that
for man how long are we going to
entertain this
how many fighters to be [ __ ] over
they have families kids training camp
coaches a mortgage rent
leases on cars they get paid for food
everything man just like you at your
work
imagine if you did your job
and the end of it because your job your
boss is biased towards i wish they would
have wrote it by hand instead of the
typewriter i'm not gonna give i'm not
gonna you know what i'm gonna do i'm
paying half this week
imagine if you went back to the water
cooler around your other employees that
went
that's judging
that's that's the way the boss works how
long would you work there
before you said something
now imagine that going on for years and
years and years
and you and you're you're a fighter and
you got [ __ ] over like holly holmer
how many fighters have been [ __ ] over
go through the list
every fight card this is an issue
every time
the mma community the mma experts the
owners go that's judging
when you say it out loud how insane is
this
how insane is it
how long do we let this go for how long
you want to do this everybody
do your favorite fighter can't afford
food for their kids to they can't pay
the mortgage to their [ __ ] ubering
because they can't afford their cars or
maybe they can't afford the coach
anymore or the nutritionist so they're
like i have to cut back on something
because i lost that last fight due to
the judges
and if i complain about on social media
i get
destroyed
and then my boss who i answer to also
agrees with don't leave the hands of the
judges so what are you supposed to do
the rest of us can make changes
but again we're brainwashed we go can't
leave the hands of the judges
that doesn't work for me try and do it
with any other sport and you sound
ridiculous
gotta make change
hopefully that fired you guys up that's
my rudy speech on referees and i the
takeaway on all this which i've been
ranting for
about an hour about judges i could go
for seven hours and give you examples
not gonna do that
because it's not that i don't care about
views but you got to have some views
right or you don't have a job so i think
the takeaway here is
dana you got to do something
you have to dude you can't say style
anymore b
wear dark colored underwear
and that's a cheat code at 39 years old
someone said what's the best advice
you've ever gotten i'd say to wear dark
underwear because literally no pun
intended [ __ ] happens okay
your boy has streaks i have streaks time
time i have streaks can't help it
that's why i like those new toilets
those bidets oh yeah they
wash your ass
this is what you got to do that's fancy
that's fancy dude i gotta get one
i gotta get one i looked in my underwear
drawer today i'm like dude i mean
am i bruce wayne of underwear it's just
all black
because i'm worried about getting
streaks you know how embarrassing is
my wife wants to get hot and heavier i
had to take money she's seen my streaks
nothing ruins the mood faster dude at 39
with two children
you're supposed to be a professional
dude you get your haircut every two
weeks you wear a nice cologne dope
sneakers jeans you always
chains classy got tattooed good looking
dude you have
[ __ ] streaks
she's out dude
she's out
i need a bidet
get up a day so i'm gonna start a
gofundme
to get him a day
but i hope you guys enjoyed that rant on
[ __ ] judging man i would love for
somebody to argue those points
because i'm here for it your boy's here
for it i've never met a fight i don't
like
not physically don't want to get a fight
with anybody physically
verbally i'm in dude
i'm like the force gump of lawyers
sometimes i make mistakes
life's like a box of chocolates
again back to the streaks and the undies
sometimes you know you think you got it
all and then you you're you're you're
hanging out all day and then you're
[ __ ] you just you drop something you
bend down like it smells like [ __ ] it's
the streaks in your undies daddy
don't get me started on toilet paper do
this again so i need a bidet because
sometimes you're wiping your ass and
sometimes
at the thick boys studios where you pay
a very high
mortgage because you own the place
sometimes you would think they would
have five ploy whatever toilet paper but
they decided to go cheap this month and
your stupid thick bratwurst thumb
pops through the [ __ ] toilet paper
goes right in your [ __ ]
yeah well it's a mess down there so you
little dukey on your hands it's
impossible to get that smell off
if i was in the clone business i'd go
what [ __ ] having it because it will stay
around all day we need whatever creates
the [ __ ] to stick around we need to
formulate whatever that is put in
cologne
because your hand will smell like dookie
for entire day
that's real dude there's nothing more
powerful than human feces and that's why
i did this show
so again the nugget for you guys
is
a good but dave can afford it
be weird dark color undies and c
quit
giving in to the narrative that
judges part of the sport
what else you got jen
very not that's a great rant dude
um
damn that was a really long rant
i have
problems
okay so again just give me like a couple
three yeah
because we got fire in the kid all right
so i i saw this meeting i got a guy
waiting out there oh there you go
this did this remember this wasn't
supposed to happen anderson silva and
then floyd mayweather because the
president had passed away yeah so it did
and it actually ended up happening and
then i think anderson got a knock down
or a knockout and then i think uh floyd
floyd beat his
sparring partner yeah hit him harder
left hook how about you need money it's
like you know i have a bit about it in
my active you know i have insomnia i
can't sleep have anxiety at 39 now which
is so weird when i started to have kids
you worry about everything and it's
leaked over into my sleep so i can't
sleep a lot these days that's why my
face is this way
that's my torch called trash panda
because i look like a
very tired panda and when i say trash
panda i don't mean a raccoon you [ __ ]
i'm talking about a fat thick panda
mowing through the trash at all hours in
the night and then he wakes up and
pandas have black eyes
i look like trash panda i've been mowing
through the trash all night worried
about the world in politics i can't
sleep because my kids the world's
dangerous so i look like a thick trash
panda that's the tour name trash panda
now you know we have merch coming too
but um
[Music]
yeah well they understand
with floyd mayweather otherwise you can
tell you yeah how much money do you need
yeah that's what bothers me a little bit
when people are like you know i've
worked with floyd brilliant brilliant
[ __ ] dude can't read but brilliant
[ __ ] dude he's so just them focused
on reading all right cool dude not to
read you know three speaks well
articulate
when it comes to businessman details
never seen anybody better not i learned
so much just being with him for
literally three days when i worked
showtime he is such a [ __ ] monster
dude he's basically the gary vee of
boxing he knew every camera angle he
knew and there was he allowed the media
and he had to ch check off who's coming
in i watched him go to people you're not
coming in
and i'm next in line like oh
show i don't know he goes you're good
i'm like oh [ __ ] and i asked a terrible
question about justin bieber never got
invited back trying to be funny i said
yo they're talking about like hardcore
fight stuff oh yo is the beef squash
between you and bieber is he walking out
the entire room went
get the [ __ ] out exit to the right fat
ass i went thank you for your time thank
you
um
but when i see floyd fighting
old sparring partners it's like
don't you have like a billion dollar
dude you have
how much money in just those bugattis i
don't know if you guys know cars those
bugattis
just to change the oil is like 60 grand
you have to
fly a specialism from bugatti either to
your house which ain't cheap he has to
be first class
it's like a whole fee or you have to
send it to a special location
back
into france you have to ship
try this out you have to ready you have
to ship your car to france to change the
oil
the cars are so expensive they are so
dope he has 10 of them
10 of them at least they're impossible
to get he has 10 of them
it's nuts
so there's no way he can be broke so
when people tell me i've worked with him
it's like
you see his staff the camera it's not
bro it's like when they say empty hammer
was broke empty hand was my manager was
a fighter in the uc he was like bro
what no he was like what's funny is the
news like oh mc hammer's bro he's like i
was m.c hammer broke i still own 17
mansions
when i was broke
i had i invested in uber and facebook
from the
grassroots
i had those investments when they said i
was broke
i was not broke dude i was flying
private when they said i was broke so
there's mc hammer and there's floyd
mayweather broke different type of broke
that's billionaire broke sign me up
daddy sign me up
but what what makes me nervous is when i
see floyd mayweather agreeing to fight
his old sparring partner a guy we've
never heard of
it you know
you want to see him drop him yeah sure
right
yeah he still looks really clean too so
check it out
floyd's in the green shorts
oh
nasty body
there's actually something funny that
happened too when the commentary team
was talking about floyd floyd answered
what i'll just play for you real quick
yeah because he's fighting a true
sparring partner
one of the things that floyd does best
by the way is psychological warfare
who's the commentators i don't know i
forgot
but my thing
i guess for floyd it's like
these are such easy fights for him so
maybe he's like i'm not doing anything i
don't have to like focus that much i'm
still gonna beat these guys and make uh
a [ __ ] ton of money i mean they're the
richest over there for sure yeah so when
you look at that forbes uh 10 most
you know uh
successful people like the richest in
the world they say the richest aren't on
that they pay so you don't put them on
that list because they want people to
know that's how much money they have so
like elon musk and jeff bezos on that
list they see some of these sheiks and
some of these like oligarchs and russia
who are dying left and right but who
escaped on their yachts and [ __ ] there's
they pay so you don't put them on that
list
gangster yeah a little too gangster yeah
so i see that with flair my house
what's going on here dude it's kind of
like you know you when a football player
retires and you seem like you know doing
these celebrity by like lamar odom like
you know you know you crack it and stuff
like that did all that stuff khloe
kardashian [ __ ] up without stuff
you know obviously money is an issue guy
made so much money but he fought
that [ __ ] nick carter
or whatever the [ __ ] yeah carter
carter dude that's my thing people go
you can do those slurry box matches
easy on the term celebrity not a
celebrity here also b
if you see an announcement on my social
media or on the show where i go hey guys
special announcement oh another special
nope i'm fighting
mario lopez in three months business
ain't booming daddy nobody's doing that
[ __ ] because they're doing well in life
yeah
it's not good so i see floyd doing i'm
like man what's really going on here
guy has like 50 cars he could sell his
cars he sells properties
i don't know i don't get it or he's like
what no i just want to compete and this
is easy work dude i made 40 million
dollars beating up a sparring partner in
[ __ ] dubai people watch because i got
to chill in dubai with my family they
flew me private you paid 40 million you
wouldn't do that i'm like yeah i'll do
that of course i guess shut up like i'll
shut up
for this money for sure i'm sure they're
making a ton of money like the logan
paul thing makes sense when he's like
it's so [ __ ] famous and he doesn't
box yeah i'll do that connor like yeah
i'm retired but this is your guy a mma
guy
yeah i'll do that yeah i'll make all the
money and it makes me even more famous
y'all do that and this dumb ass with a
splash of ct who used to be a mma
fighter he's doing comedy now he's gonna
be the narrative for the mma guy
i'll do that you know yeah the odds were
stacked against me and conor's what i'm
saying
and that's so different from celebrity
boxing which is just ah that's a tough
one but this slurry box exhibition
that's not dude but but the thing is
anderson doing work oh check him out
here dude
went to the bottom that ancient silver
body shop and then that body shop work
uh what worries me you know i was
telling jake this in person we came then
probably
i said dude if you want the resp like
his thing he says he's gonna care he
cares when he says he doesn't care about
the respect of fighters he was on forbes
top whatever 20 richest athletes i think
he was 20 at like 40 million dollars
which is nuts when you think about it
but he was like i'm making money i don't
care about the respect that's like a
comic going i don't give a [ __ ] about
anything as long as you know as long as
i'm making money you can't have that
narrative you want the respect of your
peers that's all i give a [ __ ] about
certain pairs other ones i'm like
okay but with jake you know it's like
you care about your peers so i told him
i said you going after bisping's a bad
look he has one eye
he has one eye dude he's an analyst now
he's crushing on youtube he's doing his
thing man
yeah i know you want a former champion
that's a bad look if you want the
respect
even though you probably are going to
lose you can get so much more respect
calling out anderson silva he's
currently fighting he's one of the
greatest to ever do it he beat julio
chavez jr who is 53 multiple division
world champion his dad
might be the greatest fighter of all
time
go for that guy because that's a
challenge you want our respect do that
because you think i go i know daddy
i know
your teams i can tell you this go for
him
you might lose it's worth it dude
because if you just have a good showing
you can get all the respect because
everybody in the mma community i don't
know boxing's tough to com convert but
in the mma community you beat anderson
silva
we i have nothing there's no criticism
just a few months ago he beat hulu
chavez jr dude who's you know lazy but
still 53
grew up boxing royalty
destroyed him dude [ __ ] him up
on his dad's like weird like
retirement fight whatever
was on the undercard of that the
disrespect to [ __ ] up his son and the
dad's such a savage he goes my son i
have some training with me he wouldn't
do it i thought this was gonna happen he
didn't take it serious enough i told him
wake up when he hit the road and he
wouldn't do it he slept in
yeah so if i'm jake point is i'm jake
you want all the respect you can knock
out tommy fury that's not get respect
most people including myself only know
him from love island one of my favorite
characters
great and molly
beautiful relationship they've made it
successful
but he's a reality star show
his brother just happens to be the best
heavyweight of all time
so that's the rub off on that but you
got to think about it daddy the crowd's
going to go the fans are going to go
it's tommy fury from love island dude
you've knocked him out yeah the guys
thought nope has literally fought
nobody's the worst records you've ever
seen
so that's not going to do you justice if
you want to experience go ahead and do
it but after that get on the mic do a
hot promo to fight anderson silva that's
how you get our respect
again you're probably not going to win
that one it's all good man your fan base
is still going to tune in to you
they still love you regardless now if
you get knocked down in 10 seconds awful
look you're not i don't think he gets
knocked out that fast but if you give
him a go and you get dropped bro the
amount of respect you would get and
doesn't ruin what's next
then next you said all right i'm not
answering this level man lesson learned
humble yourself man lesson learned i'm
just not there yet that guy you know
like best i've ever been in with their
current fighter yeah i got some work to
do man i'm gonna get more experience and
fight guys at tommy fury's level and
these youtubers and then once i'm ready
i'll take one last shot at a real
fighter
you know how far that would go dude just
being humble being gracious and this is
my thing
on camera obviously you know he he does
his thing and that's why he has millions
and millions of dollars but off camera
humble hard worker good dude great
family great mom and dad he's from ohio
dude
columbus just a good person his brother
great person they're just brilliant at
the market and that drama stuff yeah
he'd go such a far away
if he ate a nasty body shot from
manchester silva it was like the hardest
ever but nobody's ever hit me like that
i only have six fights man like wow i
can't believe i was in there with him
you're still making all the money
yeah great and then the goal would be
man i'm gonna go back to the drawing
board i'm gonna fight these other
youtubers just get more experience i'm
gonna fight you know some other mma
heads and then uh my goal now is to beat
anderson before i leave is to beat
anderson silva and fix judging
see
full circle back
all right so we don't have much time
left
one more all right this is all over the
place right now so michelle peare the
guy that does all the crazy acrobats
inside the cage he just won his last
fight against ponzinibio another split i
think yep so he's claimed that jorge mas
vidal's oh sorry sorry
he's claiming that jorge mazda dolls
slid into his wife's dms hmm right does
jorge want advice this is what i would
do dude i went there was this eight
years ago when you didn't have kids and
you weren't married because they're
gonna pay a different narrative just own
it dude apologize so what happened was
though actually
according to this stuff because they're
gonna keep talking about it
so michelle's like you know since he did
that i want to meet him in the octagon
so there's you know they're thinking
that he's trying to get a fight with
jorge because of that reason then jorge
posted this jorge posted this when he
posted today i think just yeah a few
hours pretty much of a savage go up
yesterday jory says how crazy a world
and how far has society fallen that this
idiot pierre would use his wife to
hopefully one day get a paycheck and
create a fake narrative to try and get a
fight with me when clearly he sees
she slid into my dms wishing you guys
the best
marriage counselor savage so there is
you can see that jorge did a story
and then she
wrote down this kill it you got this and
this is march
2021 and then he put praying hands yep
paying hands now is that it
is that the only dm that's the only dm
so she came out now recently oh
look at breaking news
society is always looking for excitement
unfortunately drama sells this is her
talking okay here we go society is
always looking for excitement and
unfortunately drama sells tell me about
it girl uh twist on the narrative to
create a story that is false tell me
about it girl uh i have never and would
never do anything to disrespect my
marriage or my husband this account as
you can see is a business account and
way more than one person has access to
it also been there um this is not even
the way i would speak
not to mention it's from years ago and
before i even knew michael okay
michael and i would appreciate respect
as we are starting a family together
there's lots of hatred in this world we
do not need to add to it peace and love
to all you underscore gina mare
underscore
here's the thing though here's i saw
this comment i couldn't help but read it
years ago years ago that [ __ ] said 2021
and how are you already his wife if you
didn't even know him in 2021 what the
[ __ ] going on bro here's the thing
interesting yo toxic baby daddy is um
you call her bro that's weird but maybe
he means bro to
uh
i mean people just say bro
yeah yeah i guess someone said wow 2021
was years ago
and then go go back over because his
original thing was
uh jorge amazon sent an emoji to my wife
the fold hands emoji he sent it to my
wife and then sent to me i never
actually crossed past him never had the
chance to ask him so i figured i really
want to understand but might as well
understand inside the outgoing okay
here's context he said exactly what
she
or what mazda's posting
and this is why i don't get down with
the click bait stuff because this is a
now this is a story on the shop show
which is my show and this is [ __ ]
isn't it but it's a fun narrative to run
with going oswald dmp or his wife you
believe that [ __ ] because you just see
headlines it's like when they're trying
to cancel joe rogan oh he's far right
and you just read the headlines like man
this isn't good they listen to show
you're like oh he's not far right at all
he's actually pretty open-minded has
brilliant minds on there i wish he had
some other perspectives on there he's
actually a good dude doing a lot of good
work but if you just read the headlines
because that's what gets clicks
especially negativity that's what's
wrong with the world and social media
and media in general that's why they're
all going down the drain but here's the
thing with mazdadoll is uh pira
said exactly what was dm'd and then the
mma community and the media runs with it
and then you know then mazda is like
wait what this is what was posted and
pierre's like yeah that's what i said
but then there's a game of telephone and
the telephone happens to be some
[ __ ] some media horse who by the time
it gets to mazda doll it's like yeah did
you hear pierre said you uh dp'ed his
wife with another fighter you're like
wait this got way out of control
you know what i'm saying yeah that's how
the game works yeah that's why i don't
play the game
that's [ __ ] that's high school drama
i'm out i got two kids i can't entertain
this [ __ ] but it made the shop show
right because this is what's current
right now in mma
which it never should have been in the
first place because pierre said yeah he
said praying hands
okay so you want to fight him because
your wife said kill it good luck it's
not like she was like i want you to suck
on my tit that'd be different then we
should fight knock gun but just a
supportive thing all good baby
but again this game of telephone with
these media
[ __ ] by the time it gets to the actual
person it's the worst thing you've ever
heard
and then society just eats it up yeah
like [ __ ] kobayashi with a hot dog
chestnut
more relevant just that
they eat it up eat it up eat up till
they're full and they throw up and then
they move on to the next one then
they're eating more hot dogs then
they're throwing up then on the next one
and then you got streaks in your undies
it's back full circle dude camouflage
that's the gem from today camouflage
undies or dark or you get a bidet you
gotta do them don't rock the white uh
whitey tighties you're probably saying
dude why you tidies yeah dude boxes for
frat boys ask your girl what she'd
prefer you in if you're in shape ask
your girl what you prefer you in
tidies
or boxer briefs boxer briefs also known
as
shorts you want to wear shorts that are
this long underneath your pants
no it's stupid
are you in a are you rushing
are you rushing for a frat you're in
boxers
are you not then we're tight underwear
like a goddamn man all right like it's
world war ii and we're fighting the
nazis that's what they wore don't you
want to be like them or do you wear
boxers and do bear bunks
and be late on your pit on your bills
full circle dude people that wear boxers
don't pay their bills on time people
that wear boxers only lease they don't
own property look it up it's [ __ ]
facts speaking of facts uh wednesday i
think it's sold out it's shauban friends
dalia trevor wallace
uh craig cohen uh craig's there and we
got jeff dye
uh we got all the monsters there
all the monsters are there that's one
show one night only and on the late show
after me at 10 p.m it's crystalline
friends i will also be on that show
chris on my show because you know what
we're friends um that is this wednesday
i think tickets are sold out if not i'll
get them like literally you're listening
this
pause it
go to thinkboy.com or hollywood improv
find the website i don't know what it is
and buy the tickets because i promise
you if you wait by the time i'm saying
this it's sold out all right uh that's
this wednesday at my favorite spot in la
that's the hollywood improv shop and
friends this will be the 9th or 10th
sold out show so let's keep it going
daddy uh and then the big one portland
oregon portland one of my favorite
freaking cities so much fun there again
i keep telling you guys it's the most uh
strip clubs per capita if i give you a
thousand guesses unless you're traveling
comic if you're a road dog you would not
know that
it's very surprising you'd probably pick
vegas
la new york miami wrong wrong wrong it
is portland different kind of city man
so portland helium june 9th through the
11th come get some portland i've been in
a hot second and i can't wait that's
also the home of voodoo donuts
so might cheat on the diet with a voodoo
donut
that being said i have to see the
dentist because i can't eat anything
sweet right now because i have four
cavities back molars left and right side
so i can't eat sweets right now but i am
losing weight so it's a very tough
predicament but i am calling uh brian's
dentist today to schedule something
before i go to portland and the only
reason i'm gonna do that is so i can eat
voodoo donuts in portland and then i'm
in san francisco i would bet my the last
dollar chin is there cobb san francisco
june june 17th through the 18th that's a
friday saturday only four shows two on
friday two on saturday that's cobbs baby
california come get some uh cobb san
francisco and then san diego this is the
uh summer tour they have san diego
california san diego laugh factory san
diego in the heart of san diego a great
club uh july 21st to the 23rd that's
where we shot the paddy pimlet uh food
truck which was my favorite guest of all
time go watch it right now uh things
doing well and then uh baltimore just
got announced today as you listen to
this baltimore and boston just got
announced today baltimore is august 4th
through the 6th
and then i'm in houston september 15th
through 17th then boston
is september 29th through october 1st
we're getting way too far down the road
but either way a lot of east coast dates
coming up portland i will see you in
june that's it takes that thickboy.com
if you want the whiskey it's also
thickboy.com that's it
get a good day we're dark underwear dana
take my advice
it's the right thing to do love you guys
thanks for watching stay thick stay safe
that's it